[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm red and I'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting uh we got to respond to some
voicemails that have been sent our way
they've been building up yeah um there's
there's some
disagreements with things that you've
said and we and listen I can take it I
can take it I don't know if there's any
disagreements to anything I've said and
um well we we uh we screen those for you
to protect your
self-image thank you thank you for that
I just came from the dentist thanks for
noticing oh what how how deep did it go
uh it there was some scraping but back
of the throat everything was fine all
the way back around the wisdom teeth
just a cleaning yep he tells me the same
thing every time you know um only 5% of
the
population uh still has their wisdom
teeth and you're in the you're in you're
in the lucky minority you need to say
you tell this to me 100% of the time
that I come here yeah it makes me feel
special like I'm in the 95th percentile
do you get a good report I get a good
report no cavitees no uh but is he like
uh you he he asked like skeptical
questions like you you flossing every
day like no do we go to the same guy the
guy in the house M you go into like a
bungalow to get your teeth cleaned you
would know it if you did you like have
to drive
through to the back and park and then
I'm about to say I don't it is a little
bit of like a duplex kind of thing but
no this is a this is like a cottage we
used to go to the same dentist and then
we both left to go to a new dentist and
I went to the dentist that my kids have
been going to yeah we parted ways cuz I
have a small mouth the size of a
child so it's easy for them to kind of
keep up they don't to do too much
switching with the equipment and stuff
but listen to what happened to me cuz I
was kind of embarrassed by this oh I get
the good report you know I I I get up my
teeth are nice and pearly and I leave
and I go to the checkout to schedule my
next appointment 6 months from
now and the woman behind the glass is is
um you know ringing me out well I got
out my phone and we scheduled we
scheduled the appointment for 6 months
from now and she says and you have an
outstanding balance um Christy and Lando
their health insurance went through but
you still have to pay I don't know 50
something dollars and I was like okay
and then I reached
down and I have my phone and I pulled
out my wallet and I sat it on the
counter uh behind her and her like
screen and
um she wasn't ready to take the card I
don't really remember what happened the
next thing I remember have no idea what
you're about to say you could go so many
ways yeah at this juncture next thing I
remember um I'm on my phone reading a
message like all these messages started
coming in and I'm reading a message and
it's a long message you got it too I'm
like reading I'm like okay business mode
I'm reading I'm reading I'm reading I'm
reading I'm
reading
and at a certain point it just occurs to
me that I've been standing here reading
my phone
for who knows how long you got lost you
got I I just I just I was just standing
there doing work on my phone and then I
like look up and I look over the glass
at the woman and she's faced completely
away from me on another computer just
doing all the work and then I look over
to the right and there's a sign right
there that says would you please not use
your cell
phone refrain from using your cell phone
while in the dentist office at the
dentist office in the line here and so
apparently this sign went up because I'm
not the only one who gets on their phone
she could have put the sign up while you
were doing your work though we don't
know you don't know how long you were
under the 20 minutes that I was put this
sign up I'm going to nail it to the wall
I'm going to turn and start doing
another job cuz I looked up I was like I
kind of came to and I was like uh wow
I've been still here I've been standing
here a long time and now she's working
on something else and I'm just then I'm
just kind of like looking at her looking
at the sign looking at the back of her
head now right and I just feel like I
didn't have the right to say like a
clicking sound um excuse me I'm ready
whenever you are I didn't say anything I
just I just stood there embarrassed and
then she finally turned around and I
picked up the card the card was on the
counter but it was and my wallet was on
the counter but it was behind her screen
and I don't think she could see it so
what I in my defense what I thought was
I took the card out and then she I was
waiting for her to grab it to ask for it
oh to take it and then when she didn't I
don't know how I got on my phone but
there I was on my phone forever and so
she turned
around I held up the C and she said okay
thank you and then she um
finally yeah I she didn't make eye
contact with me and I think she was kind
of over me well what else did you do uh
I signed the receipt and then no what
else did you do to make her get over you
before I think that was it just being on
my phone for okay a really long time I
thought you were going to say well
before that let me tell you what I did I
was oh okay no but I so I was
embarrassed that the sign was there and
but she had adopted this thing it's like
hey if you're going to be on your phone
working or whatever you're going to do
I'm just going to go about the rest of
my business I'm not going to sit here
and wait for you to get off your phone
it's a smart policy so it's kind of I
don't know it felt a little passive
aggressive but at least it wasn't
aggressive passive excuse
me and I was embarrassed but nobody
really lost there was nobody behind me
in line you got a little work done I got
a little work done yeah standing there
right in front of someone else getting
work done yeah yeah so I think your job
well done okay good but now if there was
somebody behind you I felt guilty about
it I would feel very different I felt
really stupid about it the whole way in
you know it's like cuz I I don't want to
obviously they care about it they put
the signs up that's a strong it's a big
move it's a big move to put the sign up
I don't know if I've seen a I don't know
my dentist has a sign
well when you pull out your phone to do
anything then you're in this danger zone
of getting sucked in for everything and
I I pulled out my phone to do the
scheduling and I think that's what
happens to people and she just got tired
of it she was like you know what instead
of sitting there waiting or glaring or
like clearing my throat or saying um I'm
ready when you are or excuse me or
trying to be polite to someone who in
her opinion is probably being rude she
just said you know
what I have some clarity here I can just
go about my work you might be on a list
now though I will say that I know it's
what they're next time I go in there
there's going to be a picture of me like
print it off you know how they'll do
that for shoplifters yep have you seen
this man I'm the phone lifter this man
will work for 20 minutes oblivious to
the fact that this is not his office I
really I really feel like an idiot I've
got to go in in two weeks a very so
clean teeth idiot I I'll be on a I'll be
on the lookout see if my dentist has a
sign and if they don't I'll ask them
why and I might have to I might have to
fake what I'm going to do if they don't
have a sign what you're going to do is
I'm GNA have my phone and when they when
I'm checking out I'm going to take my
wallet out I'm going to put it on the
counter and then I'm going to get on my
phone and I'm going to wait see what
happens my dentist good and then if they
say Excuse me sir sir first I'm going to
ignore them because I have to let I have
to let it sit in a little bit set in
you're trying to you're trying to
motivate them to make a sign right and
then if they say Excuse me sir I'll be
like I heard you the first time and I
was just doing this to let you consider
what it would be like if I had not done
this on purpose as a as an illustration
What okay and uh you do that my best
friends Dennis they have a sign that
says do not be on your phone back here
or something probably worded better than
that and I think maybe y'all should
consider that because how did that feel
oh not great
right yeah you're doing them a big
favor yeah let me know how it goes okay
I I'll report
back I don't get a great rep I want to
say I'm not excited about going to the
dentist
because I went you explained this you've
been to the dentist you explained this
very fresh yes I uh I'm I'm ashamed to
say that for many many years
no floss at all and except for when I
went to the dentist yeah also for many
many years I didn't even brush my teeth
at night I brushed my teeth in the
morning and you know what every time I
went to the dentist they were like great
no cavities and I was like oh yeah I got
like my dad's
teeth okay who he is in a in a in a jar
he's yeah he's never had a cavity I
think he's had one cavity and he's like
you know 76 years old or
whatever and so then something changed
and it I think it and it was
pre-pandemic
because a lot of people who went back to
the denness after the pandemic had like
build up you know because they hadn't
had a professional cleaning in like a
year and a half or something I remember
you I remember you mentioning this there
was a turn for and they were
like uh
you you've got a lot of
buildup and you need to come back every
four
months and so then I was like hold on I
was like I've never been chastised at
the dentist and I'm like okay and so I
became little Dental boy and I am fully
committed is there a logo for that I'm
working on it tote bags yeah yeah yeah I
floss without fail every single night
what every single night I brush my teeth
with an electric
toothbrush well it's not just shame it's
the fact that they were like you got to
come back every four months and I would
go back after four months and they were
like some people just have a no better
like a chemistry in their saliva that
causes more buildup you got your dad's
teeth but you your mom's saliva and I
was like but how did the I don't what
what switched cuz I like I eat better I
take much better care of myself than I
did 10 years
ago and then they're like scaring me
because they're like you know that uh
you're much more likely to have heart
plaque if you have teeth plaque like if
you have a plaque problem with your
teeth you're more likely to have a
plaque problem with your heart you don't
need to tell somebody hypochondria with
your brain man so anyway so you've been
all in on flossing for years
now I'd say since I went back to the
dentist Post covid Yeah so we're
probably talking
like to 18 months or what are the
results the results are they're like
well I'm glad you're coming every four
months when I when I show up and so this
one but are they seeing an
improvement uh they're no no they're not
like oh gosh we need to do something
different they're just like you need to
keep coming four month every four months
and I'm like man so so your flossing
isn't helping uh no I think that it
would be worse if I wasn't doing it but
I this one I'm about to go to in two
weeks maybe it's not maybe it's
pointless well in two weeks it'll be I
missed the four month so it'll be like
six months be worried when I look at my
teeth I'm like I don't see anything it's
like it's like it's like like behind the
teeth you
know and uh I don't know when you're
done eating do you like use your tongue
to see if there's any food in the back
of your behind your
teeth sometimes I floss after I eat and
brush after I eat because I've gotten so
turned oh onto this particular issue
don't worry about it ma' but basically
they they're like yeah your gums are
healthy but this could cause this could
cause
issues
and I'm like what are you what am I
supposed to do am I supposed to have a
dentist on like on
retainer is that a
pun is that a weird it became a pun that
actually started I had a you I had a
permanent retainer in the back of my
teeth bottom teeth and I was like I
don't need this anymore and I asked the
previous dentist two previous dentists
back when we were over on the other side
of town okay I was like can we just take
this out he was like yeah you can take
it out your teeth will probably shift
and look what happened to my bottom
teeth I shouldn't have done it but it
was causing worse buildup but now my
teeth are nobody sees your teeth BR I
know but they see any they see the
bottom it's fine it's fine yeah I don't
really think about it I'm just saying
that like it's fine retainer don't take
it out you're worrying too much dude
yeah but what he's talking about the
hard stuff though how's a plot getting
from the teeth to the heart he's
triggered your health anxiety well I
wasn't thinking about it and you started
talk I I literally wasn't think about it
until two weeks from now well listen and
now you're talking about the dentist and
your sign I should have just gotten on
my phone for that whole thing that would
have been funny I just realized you were
talking oh I'm doing work over here um
we're going to listen to one of your
voicemails we do want to draw your
attention to something that neither of
us are currently wearing but I'm going
to hold it okay I have worn it it's very
comfortable it is the uh what are we
calling this officially this is the
let's talk about that color blocking
sweat suit sweatshirt hoodie and uh
where are the pants do you have the
pants um the pants are color blocked
like the like this yeah the pants are
like the each leg is a different color
like one is this color and one is this
color and it's it's it's it's got the
embroidered let's talk about that on
it's very very soft on the Brites very
very stylish three different greens how
many greens can you have mythical.com
get you some of that look at that a
slightly Greener
Hood
ear biscuit is supported by Rosetta
Stone you know there's lots of really
good reasons to learn to learn a
language would you like to learn English
first yeah exactly oh that's a little
ironic uh one of the reasons is um let's
say you're reunited with a relative that
you didn't know but they spoke another
language that is an interesting scenario
that might happen to someone you won't
be able to talk to them in comes Rosetta
Stone the most trusted language learning
program available on desktop or as an
app that truly immerses you in the
language you want to learn they've used
trusted experts for 30 years with
millions of users in 25 languages
offered a few of which are Spanish
French German Korean Chinese Dutch and
Arabic rosett aone immerses you in many
ways designed for long-term retention
pick up a language naturally first with
words then phrases then sentences and
the built-in true accent feature gives
you feedback on your pronunciation it's
it's like having a personal trainer for
your accent Rosetta Stone is an amazing
value a lifetime membership has all 25
languages for any and all trips or
language needs in life a $399 program
but with our code you can get it for
just $199 don't put off learning that
language there's no better time than
right now to get started for a limited
time you can get Rosetta Stone's
lifetime membership for 50% off that's
50% off for unlimited access to 25
language courses for the rest of your
life redeem your 50% off at
rosettastone.com
today ear biscuits are supported by Etsy
it's the holiday season so we want to
talk to you about Etsy if you're like us
you're on a mission to find handcrafted
affordable gifts made by independent
sellers well whether you're searching
for custom home pieces like cutting
boards Linens and throw pillows for your
favorite holiday hosts oh yeah that you
talking about us you trying to get a
gift from them yeah yeah or if you want
personalized items like purses necklaces
and seasonal jackets for your most
stylish friends and family Etsy has it
you know Etsy is a great place to get
something that you can't get anywhere
else like I've got this wooden hand
cranked I think it's called a automaton
it's that thing that makes like a
animation I've got in the cre you got
that on yeah it's cuz it's like a
handmade craft you can't just go to the
store and get it I love that thing
whether you want a handmade craft or you
need something for that home Chef in
your life like serve wear and cookware
or style pieces like Rings clutches and
seasonal jackets for that Trend setting
special someone Etsy has it for all
budgets and for any gifting Mission are
you new to Etsy well use code holiday1
for 10% off your first purchase that's
code holiday 10 maximum discount value
of $50 expires December 31st 2023 see
terms at etsy.com terms for handcrafted
and affordable gifts for everyone on
your list Etsy has it shop
etsy.com
all right let's hear this voicemail
let's get into
it hi this is Emily um I have a bun to
pick with you guys you guys say that
pomegranates are not a good fruit and
that and no one likes them those that is
my favorite fruit the whole process is
awesome even even getting the seeds out
I just sit there and watch a video or a
movie or you guys and just peel my
pomegranate at the end of that video I
have an awesome treat to eat
that whole process is good it's like
knitting it's it's mindless it's awesome
it's it's
relaxing um so you don't go dissing
pomegranates because pomegranates is my
favorite fruit and it is some people's
favorite fruit so just saying don't go
dissing pomegranates I didn't diss
pomegranates it it was it I think it was
you it wasn't if I recall correctly
you're the one you're the one who said
that they were a horrible fruit I'm the
one who has them it's a it's a great
fruit
um okay let me think about this Emily
you've been set straight you're
watching you're watching us or a movie
uhhuh and you're fiddling with your
fruit you're fiddling with your
pomegranate
yeah it's like knitting but the opposite
it's like un knitting a
fruit and then you have like a
pile of deep red jewels to chew on on
the burst in your mouth I will say once
the Hey listen once the fruit has been
presented the fruit is magical I I as I
said before the fruit is magical the
process is so it it slows you down it's
another way that's my that's the problem
with it it you can do something with
your hands that's not your phone and now
I'm I'm totally on this my not putting
my phone in my hand anymore like don't
grab your phone grab a pomeg going put
it on a string that hangs out from keep
in my pocket it how you going to how you
going to see what's on it I'm not I'm
going to unknit a
pomegranate I'm going to I'm going to
get a hat that's much better use of time
it you need hat that has a flap that has
my phone that hangs behind my head and
when I want to see what's on my phone I
flip my head forward and it falls in
front of me and I do my business and
then I flip it back so I never touch it
it could be on The Voice brim of a hat
yeah yeah that could it could fall down
fall down the screen the phone I think
the reason that I don't relate not a
flip phone you know I respect you Emily
I respect uh you know everyone's
preferences are their preferences uh I
think maybe because I am not a I don't
approach food with patience the idea of
working now what I will do I will cook
food I will cook I will put a lot of
Labor into preparing food and there is a
payoff so maybe that's how I would
relate to this but once the food is in
hand mhm oh you don't want to
of fruit but not be able to eat the food
is in mouth very
quickly you know chocolate
milk I'm like a I'm like the Maserati of
milk drinkers chocolate milk drinkers
like you know zero to gone in 2.1
seconds you know what I mean I Maserati
milk you cannot you cannot put a glass
of chocolate milk in front of me and
expect me to savor it and listen if you
like to savor it great for you I'm just
saying I don't have that ability right I
I like the idea of using Maserati as a
verb try that I'm Maserati milk like
it's a I said I was the Maserati of milk
but I like but the milk Maserati no but
say but try on using it as a
verb um I Maserati that milk last night
that's pretty great I mean that maybe
I'm a Bugatti isn't that even faster I
think the world's fastest car is a
Bugatti what's something that starts
with a with a what's a but M Chevy I'm
the Chevy of chocolate milk what's
something that starts with a what's a
car that goes fast that starts with a CH
it's pronounced Chevy I know I was
trying to make it work what you got I
got me a new chvy I got a new chiy yeah
but they S I think it's pronounced Chevy
well it ain't a s it's a CH last time I
saw that chy think anytime you're going
to do something fast you're going to
find a fast car that starts with the
same letter so if it's milk you're going
to Maserati that milk but if it's bread
you're going to Bugatti that bread
okay I was trying to find the chocolate
part because I don't drink milk milk
real fast I'm gonna Chevy that CH we
were already there I'm gonna I'm going
to chette that I'm going to chette that
chocolate
milk I'm going to CH
chil I'm going to chil I don't know how
fast the chil is I'm gonna I'm G to
tricer I'm going to tricer that
chocolate milk I found it that's it tler
but it's not a Chrysler is not but it CH
uh yeah I bet you got be a sports
somebody there somebody out out there
has a really fast I think you have to
start with the sports car what is the
fastest Chrysler in the world do they
make Chrysler anymore my dad was so big
on Chrysler for so long yeah so big I
mean chrys Chrysler are great of a if
you're of a certain age they're but
there's a horribly made car I mean we
had and Dodge was you know Dodge was the
like
dodgy uh offshoot of Chrysler okay and
so you had those we had the Dodge
Dynasty the second Dodge Dynasty and the
Dodge Intrepid your dad was very
consistent and not having cavities but
also buying from the same dealership Co
Motor Company for decades Coast motor
company like over there next to where
your aunt used to live Oho yeah and uh
he had a
relationship you know like a he it was
just he was this his car guy he always
got used cars that had like they were a
couple years old like couple like one to
two years off the model year that we
were in okay
and I remember that dodging trepid man
when that thing came out that's where I
drove in college what year was
that 96 so you're dad drove an
Intrepid yeah that was a that was like
it like a spaceship for like basic haret
County that was a badass hey sedan that
was a fast looking car it it was
spaceship like mhm it was like a it was
like a
1998 no 199 I think it was a 96 Intrepid
wasn't it okay yeah and because it came
out in 95 a 96
Intrepid is it's like a it's like if
Tesla had a 96 car that's what in I love
to see one right now I can probably look
one up on They're All Dead they're all
off Market because is it like it
looks
that in what's the food that starts
with the sound the in sound
insela insela I'm going to Intrepid that
in Salada uh dude it was so not as cool
looking as I remember there was the one
that you had right there the one over
here at least it was big it's it's it
almost gets into like Crown Vic sort of
shaping but like it stops short of a
Crown Vic yeah it's not as great as I
remember it looks like a bullet
man oh the back that's the best part you
remember the back it kind of looked like
an electric car in the back that's what
I'm saying yeah man like decades before
an electric car I loved that car the
Intrepid it's a Dodge only electric car
completely powered by
gas I think that was their selling point
so Emily welcome to the Future uh you
know listen apology accepted is that
we're going with this I just think it's
all about what you're willing to do I
think in your explanation your defense
of your like of pomegranates you
highlighted why I don't like them you
got to watch a movie to get into this
fruit you know what I'm saying you got
to sit down and have another activity
just to eat it I want it's good to
occupy your hands grape you know what
I'm saying open the fridge pop it in
your mouth you're done you don't even
have to you don't have to chew if you
don't want to you need to work on your
fine motor skills well that's true but I
can eat a dozen I can eat three dozen
grapes without chewing one of
them why why would you do that just to
prove a point I wouldn't enjoy it at all
right just to win pomegranate AR 36
completely you're swallow 36 grapes in
order to win this pomegranate are you
what we ought to do I'm going to swallow
36 whole grapes and we're going to put a
camera in my stomach that's definitely
going to make you win the argument put a
camera in my stomach yeah to do a uh
like a time-lapse video of what happens
to whole grapes in a man's stomach okay
so you're going to swallow 36 grapes and
a camera to prove this point the camera
you could probably SW I bet you they got
a camera you can swallow in these days
yeah well it's yeah I'm a GoPro I could
probably swallow a GoPro if I had to but
I there's probably something half half
the size surely they got this in the
medical field I know they've got Scopes
they can put down there that are on a
pole or something right but I'm talking
like a capsule camera a camera with a
one-way ticket yeah and it's got a
little light or maybe it's infrared I
don't know because you got my stomach
does have a
light I don't know D I mean I'm thinking
of those those hex bugs that our kids
used to have and You' like turn on and
it would like it would vibrate and it
would make it kind of walk and you could
like make U mazes for it I bet you
that's what it is you just you I can
swallow that turn that thing on it'll
crawl right down your
throat crawl out at your bung hole you
know you know it when it's coming
too you just be afraid that the battery
might die well you going to get it out
one way or another either way it's
coming out
um let's listen to another
voicemail hi guys I just listened to the
podcast where you talked
about I don't even I don't even remember
but what I did remember was link talking
about the loofah situation he talked
about it for approximately 10 seconds I
think we need to dive more into that
because it was really validating about
how you waste so much time in the shower
trying to get all the sud out of the
loofah I didn't even know uh silicone
loofah was a thing and I want to know
more so yes if that could be a wreck
that would be good let me know where to
buy one let me know if it's it's if it's
worth the money okay thanks love you
guys
bye I'm so glad you brought this back up
I always looking for an excuse to talk
about like my shower habits yeah there's
always another way to optimize something
that you do every single day and when
I'm taking a shower I do want you to
know that every single day that I take a
shower every single moment I'm taking a
shower I am in complete embodiment of
the shower like I'm not I don't have
shower thoughts except thoughts related
to me taking a shower like I am so in
the moment when I'm taking a shower
like I'm intensely your shower thoughts
are literally shower thoughts yeah I'm
literally talking about thinking about
like now I'm watching this part of my
body now I'm watching this part of my
body now I'm doing this and I bet you
even though I've done this for 45 years
I can find a way to make it even better
a better
shower you
think maybe maybe you're like a you
could start like a some sort of shower
religion there doesn't have to be a
shower God and you don't have to be the
shower God and it's not a cult okay but
I'm saying that like definitely a lot of
nudity involved think about it exactly
you're naked is something you do every
single day so it's ritualistic yes um it
involves like touching yourself touching
yourself yeah I just it feels like it
has a lot of the elements that we would
need to start a cult if we were going to
it's good health results good mental
health results people got to do every
day you got to shower you don't have to
shower every single day but it is a
modern convention some people say you
shouldn't shower every day and you
shouldn't doctors I I saw something
recently said doctors are saying you
shouldn't shower stuff that isn't dirty
like it's it's not good for your skin
especially if you have like sensitive or
dry skin you shouldn't just be washing
everything on your body just because
you're taking another shower and I took
complete offense to this okay so this is
an interesting bit of information it was
counter to my are you saying that your
shower regardless of circumstances is
the same every time and this is a full
headed toe wash yes yeah see I've
already aded that I don't always wash my
legs but I would also tell you that if
I'm relatively clean and it's the kind
of thing that's like I could not shower
and I would no one would
know I still shower but I just make sure
to wash the the parts that would be the
first to stink the stinky Parts yeah you
got to wash your crotch your ass and
your underarms and you and you got to
wash your face because if you don't wash
your face you got in that order you're
gonna start getting yeah you're gonna
start getting some acne wash your feet
dude also do that uh yeah I yes do that
I I I should probably do that I should
probably add that to the mus watching
sandals but I will say that it hasn't
been a problem well you don't know that
you're just your fa your nose is too far
from your feet no I smell my shoes I
smell my shoes um I I accept also SM I
accept that criticism but what I'm
saying is that like what are you
thinking about this you got the the
science is not on your side I don't care
okay well that's good I want to hear it
because you're you're starting a
religion about you got to ignore the
science right you start listening to the
science it's going to fall apart real
fast just just just have faith in me
yeah there you go I'm constantly
improving my shower experience for the
good of the
Gathering uh you are welcome here thank
you for asking I saw an ad on Tik Tok
for a sud scrub a
silicon
scrubber um can I see what this look
looks like uh yeah it's uh it's like a
hexagonal hand
sized silicon rubber device and there's
like scrubbing fins in like a a swirling
circular pattern on one side the other
side's flat and you put your you put
your hand through a strap and then you
scrub yourself with it did you get the
shower hook I did not I did you get the
face scrubber I did not click on the Tik
Tock ad I saw it I scrolled and then I
found myself thinking about it the next
day and then the next day and then the
next day and I just every time I got in
the shower I was like I started thinking
about what if I had this silicon
scrubber instead of my lofo which is
like one of those like plastic
netting scrunchy looking things that you
just you squirt the you know how it
works you squirt the stuff on it and you
know how it works and you then you you
make suds and you put on you know how it
works but the problem is when I'm it's
it's kind it's almost a it's a good
abrasion and I've always like that but
they say well you need to put it you
need to throw it away every six months
and you need to wash it in your
dishwasher to get rid of the bacteria so
that's in the back of my mind but the
main thing that put me over the edge to
try this thing out and again sud scrub
not a sponsor answer um was that my
loofah when I was done using this loofah
the suds are great with a loofah the
suding factor is very high Suds are
going everywhere all on the glass walls
of my shower to the point that when I'm
done
showering I have to take the nozzle and
the last thing I have to do is I have to
wash off the inside walls of my shower
how hard are you lofing to get I'm just
like hold on how are you getting Subs on
the walls I I'll put it to you this way
my
watch um is always monitoring my
activity and then and so is my ring and
they both volunteer oh it looks like you
worked out at this time how do you want
to categorize this workout as a shower
and my phone and my ring it's not in the
app my watch think that when I shower
I'm working out right like literally you
got to call the company you gotta we got
to call AA ring
and apple health and all of them and be
like you y'all need to add showering to
your workout showering yeah I I I shower
with Reckless abandoned just like I
sleep so you're saying that like you're
rubbing so hard are going everywhere and
I don't want them streaking down the
glass walls of my shower so I don't
squeegee it but I do rinse it off all
the way and then on top of that I have
to take my loofah and I have to rinse it
out under the water and get all the suds
out because I think when the suds stay
in it it makes more of a environment for
bacteria and I don't even know if that
makes sense but that's just how I've
thought about it when it's when it's
sudsy there's like soap scum buildup
which might make a home for something
you're like a character from like
a Puritan novel where there's a man who
is like trying to wash his sin away
every single night and they like
describe the scene of him in the bath
and he's like he would vigorously rub
his skin like you're just like trying to
get like you know what I'm saying it's
like it's so I know it's obsessive it's
so aggressive it and it's so focused
it's like oh gosh this is why I don't
like to be on my phone this is why I I
like to reduce stimuli because anything
that enters my life enters my brain in a
way that like it gets it gets trapped in
there and it just bounces around and I
don't have any more room because I
shower every day and I got a I put a lot
of energy into it and I'm sitting there
trying to get all the suds out of the
loofah just running water over it
squeezing squeezing filling it with
water squeezing three four times every
single day and I'm getting annoyed yeah
it seems like a problem and I'm like I'm
going to try this sud scrub that's why I
use my hands this thing cost $30 y'all
that's absolutely ridiculous it seems
and then I started looking at knockoff
brands on like the internet you didn't
even get the subub $9 loofah $6 silicone
loofah I just read all about this though
this has got silver infused into it to
keep it from anobi antibacterial I I got
C feet and I was like you know what you
care so much about this Splurge a little
bit buy the $30 thing and see what it's
like so I bought the sun scrub for $30
not a sponsor and I started using it and
one thing I noticed is that not nearly
as much lather oh yeah as with the
plastic thing so then I had to go out
and I had to seek a high lather
soap oh independently so I had I had to
find a body wash that's really thick
what's your what was your soap of choice
and what is it
now it was um I can't remember what it
was before it was something that smelled
good that was at Target it had a red top
on it like an like an elephant as the um
logo I don't know can't remember
but the new thing that I got is and this
makes me a little uncomfortable good
it's a body wash called
thick and the biggest word on the I mean
the biggest word on the the the tube is
thick it's from duke
Canon Duke Canon thick because thick
body wash makes more Suds yes it stays
on the the sud scrub longer and allows
it to sud more now I had to learn a a
few things first of all there's a little
hole in the middle of the sud scrub that
invites a big dollop of body wash don't
put it
there don't put it there because it
won't it won't get scrambled the
instructions say put it all lather it
all over in the fins yeah and I I have
good results with that but I wet my body
I have to turn my water off completely
if you want a really good sud with the
silicone scrub you got to turn your
water off completely you got to use a
thick body wash so there's a moment
every day in your bathroom where you
turn the water off and you're standing
in a just a waterless shower and you're
scrubbing so aggressively that there's
like Suds go it's like a like a cartoon
scene like going all like I can only
imagine like when your wife I'm sure she
doesn't walk in when you're doing that
she tries not to tries not to she'
rather see me honestly yeah yeah
yeah that'd be easier to take uh but
like you I know you can probably hear it
throughout the house
like lot grunting like what is happening
up there grunting reaching I mean it's
kind of a stretch routine too to get
everywhere uh the results are good and
um yeah everything's
nice I like it I wish it had a little
more Suds than it actually does but
there's no soap throw I no longer have
to so thick it's not yeah it's not as
it's not thick enough to throw Suds
against the wall you should contact
thick and make sure they add that to
their advertising campaign no matter how
aggressively you scrub with our soap we
won't get on the walls of your shower
he's too thick he's too thick he's too
heavy I'm a little bit I'm a little bit
and I don't have to uh rinse the sud
scrub
nearly that seems to be worth it so I
feel like I have
shaved at
least 45 seconds
off of my every second counts man at
least 45 seconds that's pretty good
right um that's almost one well how long
is my shower usually 13 minutes wow as
long as you're Quicky
sex not to bring that up uh I'm a little
jealous of the thick soap though because
I I um I have to use because of the
sensitivity of my skin I have to use a
bar soap that is a brand that I don't
even know what it is like it can't have
anything in it that soap usually does so
it's just like just a bar of white you
know what I'm saying like it doesn't
smell like anything it's the kind of
thing you'd like put in your fridge to
collect odors okay you know what I mean
it doesn't it just feels I don't know
what it is sun does it lather it lathers
uh it does lather as a soap should but a
bar soap so you're already a little bit
you
know you're gonna fall behind in the
lather Department not necessarily and
and because it doesn't have some
additives that would make it super soapy
that would make it
potentially you know mess up sensitive
skin it's definitely like if you had if
you went from thick to what I'm using
you would be it would be a lot of
trouble for you you would not I don't
know how well you would adjust not going
to happen but it is remarkable for not
causing me to break out so not going to
happen I wonder if I could take that uh
the sud scrub and just rub it onto the
bar
soap I don't know I understand I
understand the principle but I don't
find myself experiencing a felt need for
it you know what I'm saying it's like oh
if if I go if I go to like a Airbnb and
they or a hotel not a airb be a hotel
that's got like a fancy hotel where
there's like a fresh
loofah
oh I'll use it because I'm like oh this
is I think people use these let me see
what this is about I mean it it
exfoliates exfoliates and it keeps like
if you get like bumps like I like on my
shoulders and my back like I'll you know
if I don't really give attention that's
why scrub so damn hard honestly is
because I'm I'm making sure that like on
my shoulders and my
midback I don't get bumps I mean I would
get an occasional an occasional back zit
not it's not a regular occurrence but
and it does happen but you have like the
red dots on your that's not has nothing
to do with that's a skin that's called
um it's not acne it's a I know it's not
acne it's a hair follicle problem and
this but I think that the scrub will
help that uh well this soap helps it
significantly like when I use a regular
soap I think the
Silicon scrubber will help with it you
need oneing sandpaper oh it's soft it's
it's soft silicone you just I might try
one when you upgrade when you upgrade
give me yours just get one man Splurge
splurge on yourself just Splurge
something I'm gonna rub on myself every
day there you go you're you're worth it
man um it'll help with your um your
Rosia I'm open to it whatever it's
called the thing I don't know I have a I
think I have a subconscious resistance
to
anything that oh if I start doing this
at my home then I'm going to have to
have it with me when I travel and I
think I there's a sub and I'm like I'm
like I got the one thing the most self
self- pressed thing that I do is I take
that soap that bar of soap in a
plastic covered thing that's the most
self-present thing that I do it's like I
got a bar of soap that I carry around in
this thing that I put into a hotel and
open up you deny
yourself the Creature Comforts just so
you don't need them and it's I mean the
only person that loses is you but also
me because then you turn it around on me
as like a judgment like whenever I was
pulling out all the stuff in my bag you
were judging me man yeah talking about
because I was be I was being I I I you
know I don't like to necessarily I'm
glad you brought this up my lip bomb the
whole lip balm thing I'm just like I'm
not accepting that as as this is an
entertainment podcast uh well typically
I mean that's the goal is to be
entertaining uh and usually my the main
thing that I'm trying to do on this
podcast is just create a fun
conversation okay so my understanding
when you break out your fanny pack on is
that you kind of know it's a little bit
funny and ridiculous and you and you
want me to point it out I do but
apparently some people but then I want
to hold it against you and some people
see that as me just always criticizing
things that you do and so next time you
break out something I'm going to be like
hey man that's a really good cuz cuz I
think this will be even more
entertaining if you you break out
something instead of busting your your
balls I'm going to be like I got it
right here oh hey how's your fanny pack
going I'm really I really wish I had one
I still got my almonds I have not isn't
that
entertaining are these almonds any good
anymore yeah it's not it's not as
entertaining yeah I want you to bust my
balls but then I'm going to hold it
against you okay period I mean
I I'm not going to let your entertaining
criticism my lip balm keep me from using
lip balm because I my lips are better
because of it well here's what I'll say
and you need a loofah and you you need
to treat yourself but the thing is is
that I'm actually not like I'm not I I
genuinely believe that if I were to take
all that from you you would suffer but
me not having it I'm actually I'm not
you don't need to worry about me I'm not
suffering when I do those things I'm
like oh I can see how somebody would be
into this but when I don't have them I
don't find myself if I was
suffering I would be I get up every
single morning and do do a really
annoying series of stretches for like 20
minutes every single day for the past
decade what's annoying stretch look
like honey did you take out the trash
here's the thing no matter what you have
to do that day no matter where you have
to go okay no matter what your schedule
is having to get up and do 20 minutes of
stretching it is
annoying but the reason I do it is if I
don't do it I won't be comfortable I am
actually into Comfort all right but I
don't find not having a fanny pack an
uncomfortable state of being okay um but
next time you you break out something
that's a little bit funny for the
purpose of a funny bit that we'll do on
this entertainment podcast I'm just
going to stop and I'm just going to
encourage
you I'm going to encourage you and I'm
going to be supportive because I don't
want this to be a funny podcast I want
this to just be two friends supporting
each other because I think that maybe
that would be that would please some
people
uh yeah let's let's try let's try that
let's just it's just two guys
encouraging one another because that
really
sells I don't yeah I don't know how I
feel about it but uh I think I feel good
about it okay hey man you're looking
great
today thank you I love your gray
shirt you know just two guys sitting
around two guys just sitting around
complimenting each other and encouraging
them in all the choices that they make
because give me something give me
something um we have another voicemail
oh yeah hey what about what about saying
something encouraging to me because if
you don't say it I'll be mad and I'll be
sad and then all the people who are
worried about me will spend a lot of
time worrying about
me if you don't encourage me then people
are like oh what's why is he like why
does he encourage him this is funny does
he not you're funny you the way you're
tapping into irony for humor is funny I
just think he's so insecure that he has
to make fun of other people because he's
insecure about
himself ah you got
me you nailed it sounds like you're
reading more comments than me sometimes
I make a mistake and and read I'm just
saying sometimes I do um okay all right
great ideas great great humor thank you
for that great humor there yeah thank
you for that um let's get this followup
to the sports
conversation hey guys I was just
listening to the most recent podcast
where you guys were talking about what
is more of a primal experience than
being really engaged in screaming in a
sporting event and I have to say I think
metal concerts are the way to go if
you're wanting to experience that in a
non-sporting uh event because people
really just like let themselves go and
it's someone that's not really into
metal but I recently went to my first
metal concert it was a really fun
experience to see people like you said
get in that like Primal State and really
just let loose and have fun it's super
entertaining and it's definitely a safe
place to kind of go a little
wild this makes sense to me I've
actually observed interesting some um I
feel like the people that I've known
personally who have been really into
metal and even people who've played
metal yeah tend to be some of the like
most calm and well adjusted people and
then when I like see them
do their thing and they're they look
like they're possessed by a demon yeah
I'm like this is crazy but then it's
like they get it all out and so you know
there was all whole satanic Panic thing
and all these parents are like all these
kids are like listening to this dark
music and it's going to make them bad
all the
time but I think that for a lot of kids
it's like yeah I get to go and I get to
do something physical with like listen
I'm not a mosh guy I mean that that
whole the whole idea is yeah I don't
like to be I don't want to be hit in the
face I don't want that well it's
interesting that but I get I get it I
get the release she described it as a
safe
space and she was being introduced into
backhanded into the
teeth well I think it's that no one
there is like
murderously
demonic they're all there to enjoy the
music but maybe some of them they so Des
very very small percentage a scenario
where everybody is on the same page
which is it's just a cathartic release
of energy yeah even a I guess aggressive
energy but just think about it that when
the right kind of song comes on just
like I mean it reminds me of when we
would hot box is not the right word CU
that involves smoke and there was no
smoke or smoking involved in when we
would we'd close all the windows to the
Dodge Intrepid or whatever car it was we
would turn up the heat especially when
there four or five people in the car
during the peak of summer in North
Carolina so we're talking like it's 90°
outside while it's dark turned heat all
the way up played really intense music
and like headb trash in for like 30
minutes all the way to Raleigh we would
get out of we get out of the car to go
into the movie and we'd be a sweaty mess
like where would these guys like we
would get so sweaty like like sauna like
if you went into a sauna and just
thrashed and headbanged it was like hot
yoga that's what that's the LA
equivalent yeah that's that's what it
was We Invented Hot Yoga yeah hot car
yoga there was no yoga though though it
was metal music uh boy those were the
days and you feel like you feel alive
you feel alive after that well cuz when
you got out of the car even though it
was it still might be 90° outside then
it felt cool yeah it felt cool it felt
so cool to walk out to the we felt it
was the only way to make North Carolina
in July feel cool right was the hot box
basically we we I'm surprised we never
had a name for it if we would have
actually named it something we would
have probably done it even more often
we'd probably still be doing it probably
still be doing it sweat
car car
sweats car sauna sauna
car vehicle hot hot vehic you got to get
the it's got heavy
heavy heavy Sonic car heavy Sonic
car we'll work on it um yeah I I this is
this totally makes sense to me though
yeah um you get you get maybe and listen
I assume there are people who don't like
they don't have it they don't have
something Primal that has to get out and
a scream that has to get out every once
in a while I guess it is sort of
Personality
based but but even if you're like
stretching of a morning like you do like
if you're just like if you're just like
oh you know your body just tells you
this is
stret and then if you just let out a GU
to go just let it let it just let
whatever's in in there out vocally
oh yeah it feels good where am I oh yeah
am I inside or outside oh man hopefully
you're like about to jump in a mountain
stream or something you
know I'm gonna start doing that I'm G
start having a just a are you g to add
this to the to the things you do a
vocalization yeah I think that is a
great idea I can't wait to I would love
to be there when you do it but you you
need need to vocalize when you're
stretching I would really you know what
link that idea to be really loud fill
your lungs and just empty it that that
idea to be louder than you already are
with your scrubbing is a really great
idea and as your best friend I just want
to say you come up with so many great
ideas and all the little choices that
you make in your life are really perfect
for
you yeah you know and it's just like
every little weird thing no no every
little cool thing that you do yeah it
just makes me like you more oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you for saying
that like so if you if maybe you what
you could do is you can invite me over
when you're getting ready to make some
Primal noises and I would just sit and
watch you and clap
clap and uh but if you don't want to
call me if you want it to be your
private time you could just film
yourself and send it to
me that would be cool I'd like to see
that you're that interested in it yeah
yeah yeah yeah and you send me these
little pictures and hearing about it
wasn't even those of you stretching
making noises maybe even some of you
scrubbing yourself and I'll just look at
it on my phone and I'll
clap I'll I'll clap for you I mean
there's been times in therapy where I've
you know he'll be like breathing and
then when you breathe
up oh you got you're doing that kind of
breathing I've done that in therapy I
just sat there and like if I feel like
real voluntarily or did they you we were
asked to he guided me to do it oh okay
he called it Vu breathing and and then
we're sitting there and it's just like
have you have you ever done that a Vu
breathe variation yeah mhm and it
rattles your cavities and it it settles
you like if you have like butterflies in
your
stomach and you just breathe in
compassion and you breathe out judgment
and you're
[Music]
like you know you feel like feel like an
I mean that's animalistic it's a release
it's it's all a
safe release excrete it do you have to
spray compassion in the air
first before you breathe it in or is it
just already in the air like it's a
component of the air like some oxygen
some nitrogen some hydrogen and a little
bit of compassion and if you just
breathe good enough you'll get
it I no I believe in I believe in the
breathing exercises I fully support
those I'm just boasting your balls man
but it's not funny and no one likes it
it's not entertaining so I'll stop doing
it so yeah whether I'm just insecure man
I listen I'm just insecure whatever it
is I I'm kind of jealous that you're
breathing that hard with your therapy
appointments I we breathe at the end of
pretty much every therapy appointment I
know my therap appointment was coming to
an end when he says shall we breathe
together oh I know the thing is I know
my therapist would be very if I were to
say hey uh let's do some breathing he'
be oh I've been waiting for you to like
I know he's a breather you know what I'm
saying he's he's a very breathing guy he
he doesn't he knows that you're not uh
you're not much into breathing no that's
not true he knows I'm like I've been in
La for a decade you know what I mean
like I I'm and I he's waiting for you to
bring it up and I no no I'm just saying
it hasn't been a part of it it's a nice
way to end a therapy session where it's
like I mean so much of my therapy is
just a it's about self-judgment so much
of it
so it's nice to enter a meditative state
of
acceptance period I mean and so it's
just like a
nice it's a nice um linal space before
going out back into the rest of Life
little reset yeah and it also makes me
feel like oh we're done probably makes
you sleep better too I did it
uh speaking of heavy
metal I this ties in nicely to uh yes a
news item I read like to explore now you
may have heard uh I don't think we
talked about it on this podcast I think
we did yeah did we
um like this this whole year oh yeah we
talked about it when we talked about the
fact that we saw orcas while we were
diving but this year I think mostly if
not exclusively off the coast of
Portugal orcas killer Wales have
attacking boats and they've been doing
this it is a sudden Stark increase a
obviously coordinated attack like first
of all we have no idea we have no idea
how intelligent these animals are first
of all right their brains are larger
than
ours uh I think we will be one day when
we are able to tap in we will be blown
away with the level of intelligence
different a different kind of
intelligence right they don't wear pants
but there's definitely
a in some ways probably in typ certain
types of intelligence probably more
intelligent but set that aside for a
moment they have an ability to speak to
one another in a relatively complex
language sure that they can coordinate
things right and so the theory go for
the Ruder has been that incapacitate the
human vessel that's exactly how they
sound too this one I think her name was
white
glattus yeah uh the theory is that white
glattus was disgruntled maybe she was
hit by a ship or something like that or
a boat and then she started doing this
and then Revenge it either just caught
on like I like like white glattus is a
natural leader so whatever white glattus
does they do but it has like caught on
regionally and they've been attacking
boats so much so that people in this
area are trying to come up with ways to
combat it and one of them is playing
heavy metal music underwater yes and
these so these Sailors created a
playlist called metal for
orcas I'm going to read some of the
titles here it's 37 minutes I guess you
got 37 minutes to like get rid of
the um
orcas fatal
invocation is the
opener and Then followed by the blood of
Power by dying feet
which is quite a pleasant name for a
band yep exceptionally sadistic is track
three infinite Terror then stretched and
devoured no Orca wants to be stretched
and devoured going back to what we were
just talking about a moment ago this
listening to this
playlist really may just you could
release all your
aggression it might F the orca's
aggression I mean dead but still alive
martyr
no half measures from
ingested you're in a band yeah
ingested well you might be surprised to
know according to this Business Insider
article during an encounter one day in
November rush I guess is the Sailor and
his crew tried out the musical trick on
a gang of
orcas but the determined dolphins do I
guess technically I don't know the
determined dolphin succeeded anyway
striking the boat's Rudders and
disabling it steering so that's what
they've been doing they've been going
for the rudder because they know if they
knock the rudder off then they can't
keep doing their thing
MH but I just it didn't help in this one
scenario this is anecdotal this is one
thing but might have made it worse if
the if the heavy metal if the thing you
don't like is emitting a sound you don't
like and you already have been doing
something to this thing that you don't
like right now you're just giving it
more reason to not like
it I think I'm understanding why this is
not working and can you imagine what is
first of all one of the things that has
uh I know I can't remember somebody
smart was talking to me about this I
don't know who it was and I'm
paraphrasing but essentially the level
of noise pollution that is in the ocean
because of all the stuff that we are
doing and all these giant ships and
stuff
uh it's pretty annoying you know these
these these whales are going for
millions of years just let's no other
sounds I mean there's the sounds of the
ocean but they're doing their thing and
speaking to each other and now all of a
sudden there's these sounds going it's
like oh while this freighter is going by
like none of our we can't talk to each
other you know this is a problem these
things whatever they are that showed up
here in the last couple thousand years
they're really causing a lot of problems
out in the ocean and and uh maybe
they're def finally like okay well what
are we going to do about it
guys I think the
long-term play here might be that they
really get into heavy metal music that
would be and then when they finally are
able to speak to us they say we love
dying fetus right they're like very oh
what is they like everybody
misinterprets it like they love oh they
love dying
fetus oh gosh these orc these orcas are
they just they want all the fetuses to
die just the
band
they're really Pro abortion I really
like abdominal putridity no it's just a
metal band it's just a metal band guys
that's what they'll
say I mean there is another band we'll
be ready when those when those whales
start talking we'll be ready is it
there's a totally different band called
aborted it's like what what they try to
come up with some of those like very
divisive and death related
and oh yeah that's our sweet spot you
want you want a little Darkness you want
Darkness to what should we name our band
I was thinking aborted well there's
already a dying
feetus you know it's like what are these
conversations like and and probably what
you just did if but but again these are
the nicest people you've ever met is
that what you're saying I think uh well
again I'm not speaking for Psy aborted
or dying F I would like to go deeper in
the
psychology of metal band names well here
okay like if I just click on Extreme
metal and just read sepul seal
curse you know
Carnation cursed minis Mor okay I like
that one well here's the thing about
like the satanic Panic from the 80s
right Undead so did you have a whole
bunch of people and they're doing it
again now like dead space like Lil Nas
you know and like DOA cat are kind of
doing the same thing where it's just
like they do these things kind of lean
into the satanic panic because they
because it's like it's gets the clicks
man here's what devangelic
uh but the thing is is that kneel before
death um I let me see if I can continue
to try to gather my thought here um they
are doing these there there's most of
the people involved in it like for
instance like the whole the Church of
Satan is these people don't they don't
believe in Satan like they it's a it's a
because in order to believe in Satan you
have to believe in the Christian
framework in order to get Satan you
understand what I'm saying so it's not
like when I was a kid and they were
telling me there's Satan worshippers I
was like I remember thinking one time I
was like well Satan is a concept that it
was invented by like you know like
Christian doctrine right and uh he's
like everyone knows that he's like the
loser ultimately so why are we all why
are we all on the losers team when we
know that he's like the bad guy right
but that was it's not happening like
those people are taking it's like a
religious liberty movement and so they
use the basically this icon from you
know from Christian doctrine in order to
identify themselves as an example of
religious liberty that's what the whole
point of the movement is however if you
are the kind of person because there are
some people out there who are like I'm
going to try to move towards the most
the darkest thing possible and may
actually like believe that they're
worshiping some entity called Satan
they're probably going to listen to this
kind of
music as well so you're going to get the
because this is like the darkest
available music so you're going to get
those people but I'm just saying that
the the uh the
mass the the the vast majority of those
people are just like this is just a fun
thing to listen to to kind of get some
aggression out this a theory at least H
okay I'm
not willing to like actually listen to
this stuff it's just I it's just I don't
think it's for me you a little bit
scared I'm a little bit scared I think
you should play it while you shower I'm
a little scared of nameless Mist you
know what I'm saying like it would
actually complete the full picture for
me not to give you advice or to try to
critique your Technique because I
wouldn't do that because I'm your best
friend and I only encourage you in all
your choices but just I would say maybe
take it under advisement
next time you're in shower mode shower
goes off scrubbing starts blast some
dying fetus and a you don't even have to
have a waterproof speaker because the
water's off at that point some disguised
malignants perhaps and just see how it
feels I mean think about how much more
you can exfoliate to dying fetus oh my
gosh you might rip a whole layer of skin
off but you won't get back
zits Josh probably has a really great um
metal playlist for you all yeah Josh is
for shower that's where that's where he
goes he
go and I've been to a few metal concerts
they they are fun they are fun are but
you are you on this outskirts of the
thrashing uh usually yes cuz I've I've
only gone to like small metal shows like
around La like it's not like a
full-fledged concert but oh um that
sounds awkward punk shows can be just as
aggressive as metal shows as far as like
mosh yeah pits go but typically um I've
I've been in mosh pits before and
typically they're very um civil and
they're always nice to me but if you all
try to get in them you'd be targets cuz
you're so tall but and don't even get me
started with SCA I mean who wants to who
wants to bring a Trum bone into that mix
nobody yeah yeah there's a lot of scy
bands man that was a that that and all
the that Trend kind of died because you
got to you carry that brass section
around and to Too Much overhead they can
be difficult to deal with as brass
players you got a wreck baby wreck baby
one 2 three 4 I uh I recommended Dan
mclen before his Tik Tok Channel and
he's a
uh biblical scholar who makes uh
actually very entertaining content
because of just the way he breaks things
down um and but he has a podcast now so
if you're the kind of person who was
into that wreck when I made it about uh
his Tik Tok
channel uh you should check out his
podcast data over Dogma he does it with
a friend Dan another Dan okay and uh
they basically it's it's essentially
more of like a deeper dive and they have
experts on talking about different uh
particular issues again it's very like
Bible geek stuff which is a niche that I
am in if you're also in that receive
with caution you will really like you
will really like it if you like his uh
uh his Tik toks I wonder if they eat the
noodles when they're
together the noodles Dan Dan danan okay
two Dans I was like okay Dan Dan noodle
that was good that was good that was
that was a really good joke best friend
thank
you it didn't require any explanation I
just had to think about it for a while
then be told what it was there you go
there you go all right hey we like
getting your
voicemails um especially when you're
setting a straight so yeah give us
another call 1888 earpod one or use HH
your biscuits we'll talk at you next
week hey R and L this is TIY from for
Collins Colorado I've called before I
love your podcast I'm listening to your
newest one and I just want to let you
know from uh for mountain time that
means we're on our own clock so yes
mountain time is a time zone but
mountain time is kind of slang for we
just kind of go with it love
you to watch more ear biscuits click on
the playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the cirular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical
best